Hillary Clinton said Trump is an
illegitimate president and this is
September of 2019. that's interesting
she's a sweetheart hold on a minute
gotta love oh yeah that's three years
after the election yeah what do you
think about that that's not right off
the bat and she's still saying it three
years later what a what a irresponsible
woman to say something like that you
don't like this kind of stuff right well
you shouldn't be doing this
so if that's irresponsible for
everything Trump said about bideness no
what I'm trying to say no right what I'm
trying to say to you that is
irresponsible okay so show me everything
Trump's she said that three years after
the election that's the point that yeah
that that kind of hurts your argument
though no it doesn't yeah your argument
is Trump was saying that a year later
six months later she's saying that till
today Trump Trump's still saying that
and Trump will say until he dies
why but why why does her stuff not get
censored but God forbid somebody on the
right says that it's illegitimate that's
not okay tell me how that's okay but the
other one's not okay there's a
difference and by the way that's not
okay and I've called that out and I'll
continue to call it up right but you
didn't even know it was three years you
looked at it you're like but this was
you until you realized the date was 19.
because what I knew was this what
when Hillary lost yeah
the following morning she conceded let
me finish she conceded in front of the
country congratulated Donald Trump and
said I'll do everything I can to help
him become a successful president
Hillary Clinton then showed up at uh
president Trump's inauguration Hillary
Clinton participated in that transfer of
power even though you knew deep down she
probably felt that way but she was man
enough to do it
because she may have done this woman
enough there's a lot of controversy
these days surrounding that joke you
shouldn't be true she did those two
things okay but she also was then
immediately on her own tour she was she
was on The View that's where she kicked
it off and she was everything else was
she at the inauguration you're right she
was did she I think and stand in front
of a microphone the day after yes she
did but she was isn't that don't
downplay that my friend isn't that
really important
don't [ __ ] minimize that if you love
this democracy and we are in a [ __ ]
divided country where we're at each
other's throats and every election is
close and man it's hard to lose it sucks
to lose for you to stand up in front of
the country so the country can know yes
I concede I lost he won he won
legitimately this is how our nation
works I will do all I can to help him
become a successful person don't
minimize that I'm not minimizing I said
both should be truly important Joe Joe
Trump didn't have the [ __ ] balls to
do that but she also went to the
inauguration and this is what past said
Pat was very open about this he thinks
that Trump should have gone to the
inauguration guys I didn't I didn't say
I gave credit already to that part
that's already been addressed but for
him
three years later she's still saying it
today she's still saying it okay just
everybody knows so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
all right
[Music]